uh why don't we go next to I hope I
pronounced this correctly is it Kumi
from Missouri
kumei
Comey
you're muted Comey you have to unmute
yourself I've unmuted you but unless oh
it's coming sorry kame welcome to the
program
I've come to Colin about uh well
yesterday's uh January 6 committee
findings
apparently just cut out
oh I cut out
all right go ahead let's see if you can
get the question in
okay so according to the sixth committee
the Turner Diaries was used in the
planning of the assault on the capital
if you don't know it's the Neo-Nazi
Manifesto used by the far right in many
cases of terrorism like Oklahoma City
yep
and do you think there's a possibility
that they could cause like an eventual
rise at the far right and set off in the
future that what would cause that the
Turner Diaries
no just casual insertion of white
supremacists talking points
oh uh you know I don't expect uh no I
don't I don't think so I don't that's
not a major con I have many many
different concerns but I can't say that
that's one of them
I mean you have Tucker Carlson that Fox
News a point of strings and inserting
the great replacement
yeah no that's true I mean I guess
I guess it depends on whether you
consider all of these things part of the
same movement or not but I mean yeah
listen Maybe I guess I just don't think
about things in those terms if people
like Tucker and others start and they
have been sort of weaponizing these
ideas they're putting their own spin on
them and making them sort of something
new and of themselves even though it's
linked to something else so uh yeah I
mean I guess to some degree but I don't
necessarily see things as so kind of
siled in black and white
here in Missouri
we're dealing we have to deal with a
barrage of anti-trans laws yes
hypocritically one of them was found out
to be a child molester
one of the people pushing the laws uh
yeah oh that's not surprised that's old
hat that that's that's it would be
surprising if that wasn't the case
true every conservative accusation is a
confession at this point it is it's
incredible I mean I haven't heard of the
specific one but we've seen that all
over the country
and also the groomer accusations are
getting pretty violent like proud boys
attacking uh drag queen story hours and
some people bringing long arms to Disney
World
it's an insane insane world out there
it's crazy
it is
all right well thank you for the call I
really appreciate it you're welcome all
right there we go always great to hear
from people from Missouri very very
important